[Music]  just a few weeks ago it was reported  that the transformers franchise had been  put on hold due to cinema closures and  the lack of a director  but at least the latter point could be  improved because as deadline reports  the 32 year old creed 2 director steve  caple jr  is currently being considered for the  production of the sixth part although  contract negotiations are still in  progress  he is the studio's top choice as  transformers director michael bay has  not been available since the fifth part  and the spin of bumblebee was taken over  by travis knight  caple jr could soon bring a breath of  fresh air to the successful franchise  by the way transformer 6 will not be a  direct sequel because the script by joby  herald is supposed to take the saga  in a completely new direction what  exactly is meant by this is not yet  clear  but fans can look forward to the us  release date on june 24  2022  [Music]  you